[Music]
hey everybody what's going on yeah
all right so we now saw this one at 10
10 o'clock last night that was the only
showing that it had at our theater it
was like at 9 55 p.m we didn't get out
there till like midnight and there was
only one other guy in the theater yeah
it was a monday night though he was
tripping there
he was tripping he was like what the
[ __ ] what well i mean he knew that it
was the cronenberg i guess he knew he's
coming right like yeah because i heard
him say like a couple times like
cronenberg
because i think you said that a couple
years i walked out my cronenberg
big old he's a big old dude with the
[ __ ] cane yeah yeah yeah
okay is the movie any good i know those
people go is it good you know i'm
waiting for it to stream you know and
um yeah yeah it's good i kind of um
it's kind of like a cross between
video drone
naked lunch
and brood
kinda
got a lot of existence and yeah i didn't
see that one so i can't make that yeah
it's uh it's one of his good ones
um
some weird [ __ ] man he cronenberg's the
[ __ ] out
on several occasions through the whole
movie
yeah pretty much yeah they got a dude
named viggo what's his name nico
martinson viggo mortensen and um yeah
he's in a lot of stuff he was probably
he's probably best known for the lord of
the rings movies but he's been like okay
he's older guy he's how old do you think
he is 60s i have no idea yeah he's in
good shape though uh looking good
[ __ ] and the women are loving on him
in the damn movie and [ __ ] and what he
is is he's a
performance artist he he's like a
rembrandt but what his skill is is to
grow these weird mutant
[ __ ] organs inside his body
and they got some kind of registry in
the government you got to go register
these organs as they're born or
something and they got to be taken out
of you they don't let you grow them i
guess
and uh there's a whole club scene
where you have these surgeries and every
everybody's taking pictures and loving
it while they're taking things out of
your body
his assistant is uh that who is
is played by the same woman who did
double 07's or james bond's girlfriend
his wife
cute chick she's in it and she busts
them out too so you get to see her
oh
in this culture surgery is the new sex
yeah that's the lion from them so yeah
so they for them it's like a sexual
experience it's like a live sex clubs
but it's surgery
it's it's being filmed in greece
somewhere they didn't say greece but i
could i recognize it as greece yeah it
was crazy it was great it was athens
actually athens yeah all these old
buildings all [ __ ] dilapidated looks
like a [ __ ] blade runner in a way
uh but more kind of rural
so it looked really good
turns out not only is he this artist
he's also an undercover sp secret agent
of the cops
and the the cops are trying to keep
track all these people with these weird
mutant organs that are being grown in
them
there's another cult in there it's like
something out of the brood they're
making plastic food and people and and
some people can eat it and they can live
they love it and other people eat it and
it kills them
they got these weird beds that look like
a damn half a wall not you laying it and
it [ __ ] rattles you and shakes you
and [ __ ] it kind of it it looks by it
looks biomechanical
and it's to uh
and what it does is it [ __ ] it helps
you sleep better
by anticipating your pain and discomfort
and then they got special chairs you sit
in like bones that [ __ ] contort you
and [ __ ] while you're eating so you can
digest normal food it's [ __ ] bizarre
[ __ ] bizarre this this
most people have evolved in a way where
they don't feel any pain so these
surgeries they don't even require any
anesthesia and they don't get infections
anymore either so they don't have to
clean [ __ ] you can just like cut people
open in a in an alley yeah
like nobody nobody gets sick from it
yeah and the cops are worried about
these people that can eat plastic
i get you know uh i don't know why
they just they're just worried about it
there's more and more of them every day
um
yeah they're almost they're like a
they're like a cell of like i guess you
would sort of call them like eco
terrorists but yeah yeah it's sort of
like well now here's the thing this is a
movie i kind of want to
see this one again because a bunch of
secret [ __ ] was happening i couldn't
well it's very okay it is very
expository yeah uh there's a lot of
really disturbing images i don't think
it'll be disturbing for anybody that's
familiar with david cronenberg's stuff
because it's you know very kronenberg
and yeah it's about like video drone
kind of yeah and i mean there's like
some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i heard
like when it premiered at can even
though it got like a standing ovation
from some people like i heard like some
people walked out and i was like what
the [ __ ] were you even expecting but
okay
but
it is like really
philosophical so there's a lot of scenes
of like philosophical discussions
um about
art and surgery and various things like
that so it's kind of like pretentious
but it's meant to be pretentious because
i kind of get the feeling that it's
satirical in a way yeah but yeah so
there's a lot of stuff going on in this
that like i said because my hearing is
bad too a little bit so i'm used to
having um you know the the closed
captioning on like when i'm at home and
obviously in the movie i don't have that
so a lot of times like i think i missed
like some of the dialogue so this is one
when it comes out on streaming i'll
probably watch it again so i can get all
the stuff but i think i kind of caught
what was going on like the guy
whose kid got murdered at the beginning
he was sort of like the the head of the
cell now
they were
they had altered their bodies right to
be able to be able to
digest plastic or
or they they could digest it wasn't just
plastic it was any kind of like harmful
like man-made materials like you know
any kind of like like radioactive sludge
or anything like that i think they could
eat anything like that yeah but the
thing about it was that they had altered
themselves in such a way that
then there was like a kid born that had
it that was born like that naturally
yeah it's kind of like their messiah so
yeah so it was kind of like evolution
was going in that way and so there's
like two different factions of like you
know we should evolve in that in that
direction and see what happens or
we shouldn't evolve in that direction
because viggo mortensen's character
whose name is saul tenser by the way um
his whole thing is he's really good at
growing all of these vestigial
organs um but him and caprice his
partner
they just take them out like as
performance art and then like so it's
kind of like a crisis where it's like
well should he not take them out like
you know should he leave them in there
and like see where evolution goes and
like all this other kind of stuff they
have this it's not set i mean i guess
it's supposedly the future but they
don't tell you when it is or where where
or where it is it's just it's very much
its own it's in its own universe
universe like they don't really tell you
like what happened like why the world
ended up like this like how long it's
taken nothing like that yeah there's
nothing futuristic in it everything's
actually real right it's very yeah it's
very like yeah i was i'm trying to like
think of what the word it's very very
mannered it's very
emotionally cold
but i get it you know it keeps you at
arm's length but i guess most of
cronenberg's movies kind of do that it
does have
what i was saying it reminded me a lot
of existence and existence came out in
1999 and that was actually like the last
sci-fi body horror film that he did
before he went more into like crime
drama
but
this reminded me of existence in a lot
of ways because they have like this
autopsy machine that they use like for
the surgeries called a sark and it's
like this big like sarcophagus type
thing
and
made out of bones yeah like the controls
of it is very much like the controls
from the game in existence where it's
like this organic thing where you kind
of like caress it and that makes it and
then it like lights up different colors
it's like a bug kind of it's kind of
reminded me of naked lunch like you know
i remember the typewriter and everything
and he's like you know making love with
the typewriter the typewriter became an
ass [ __ ] that was a weird that book
is weird to do his [ __ ] triple balls
we should probably like review that one
of these days because i haven't seen the
movie adaptation and a lot you haven't
seen oh you've seen it though before
i've seen it it's just been a long time
since i've seen it yeah it's just uh you
know i don't want to [ __ ] you don't
want us the movie's new so you don't
really want to spoil everything about it
um it's just um
it's good
it's good i would say
you know it's along the same lines as
as as classic cronenberg the brood and
videodrome and gave me a little bit of a
crash vibe too i didn't see it so i
can't but but that was based on a novel
though like that was based on jg ballard
novel just in the sense of there being
like surgical stuff being like sex you
know what i mean like people getting off
on being cut up yeah uh so there was
that kind of thing it was crash had a
search similar kind of thing which
actually now that i'm thinking about it
now that i'm thinking about not like not
even cronenberg movies that movie that
came out last year called titan that
french movie was actually kind of like
crash as well but like people that were
sexually aroused by machines that they
didn't have so much of that in this this
reminded me a lot of existence but
again i haven't seen that in a long time
either just the imagery reminded me of
that i will say that
some of this stuff in here i guess what
made people walk out because i heard
that there was walkouts like when this
was at the cannes film fest festival
like in the first five or ten minutes
i'm guessing it was because of the kid
i'm guessing yep i'm guessing that's why
people like um walked out and that
actually it's probably good they did
because it gets like way more [ __ ] up
than that like later on yeah they're
soft
i guess yeah it's soft either
people either that or like well like i
said it's like it's cronenberg what the
[ __ ] you yeah
his whole thing is horror his whole
thing is like hey let's cut open our
stomach and put a zipper in it and then
like you know reach our tongue in there
and like poke around in everyone's
organs yeah tattoo their organs while
they're still inside there's
what two generations maybe three
generations of people that didn't grow
up with cronenberg and videodrome and
the brood and they would be probably
highly insulted by that but that's just
[ __ ] you yeah i mean [ __ ] you but the
weird thing about it is that i kind of
feel like maybe they i maybe sometimes i
think they kind of like hype that up
like oh people walked out because
that'll make people go see it because
honestly a lot of people really seem to
like it they said it got a six minute
standing ovation like at the end of it
so obviously most people yeah there's
yeah another another thing is is that
for by cronenbergian um standards
it's not unusual it's more kind of like
a return to what he was always doing
yeah a definite return to form it's just
like return for this and i wonder
because when i was saying earlier that
it was like similar to existence it's
because he wrote this movie or the first
draft of it way back in 2003 i think
which was only like four years after
exit sense came out so he was still kind
of like thinking along those lines
because existence if you haven't seen it
is more like a like a virtual reality
kind of game but it's all like organic
they have like this plug that goes into
the back of your uh spinal column and
it's all like you know like the
controller is like a fleshy thing that
you
rub on like to get it to do [ __ ] so it's
kind of like that but he wrote it back
in 2005 they were gonna make it
um and then he was gonna come out in
2006
and then it just never got made and he
said [ __ ] it and he just like lost
interest but then like a couple years
back he got back interested in it again
and then diego mortensen came and i was
wondering like when we were in the car
on the way home i said i wonder is he
going back to body horror because now
his son is making movies i don't know um
you know what i mean i didn't really i i
haven't like seen something [ __ ] too
yeah i mean if you haven't seen like
brandon cronenberg has only made two
movies he made uh anti-viral and uh
possessor obviously but those are both
like excellent so i'm just kind of
wondering i need to get those
yeah i don't think you saw anti-viral i
did but we saw possessors yeah i liked
possession yeah i liked it a lot too but
they i mean they have like similar
yeah they they have like a similar
themes that they are like obsessed with
conan burke was oh you know i liked
cronenberg because he he'd always kind
of come up with some kind of weird
concept based on something that was
really happening a video drone was about
[ __ ]
manipulating and controlling people
through screens television screens that
this television screen is them is the
mind's eye or it's a way of interfacing
into your brain
and changing not only
how you see reality but changing your
reality and then changing your physical
body
that was the idea there
brood the brood was kind of like that
how
oh these self-help places okay could get
you to exteriorize your emotions okay
and he's kind of
being okay
and and it gets to the point where
you're actually giving birth to your own
[ __ ] emotional children and [ __ ] to
god kill people you know
but he was always trying to find
some kind of darkness in in in what was
going on in society like well what if
it's really this or what if you
you know let's turn it up to 11 what
would that be like you know that's
that's what that's what he was good at
with this one i think what he's talking
about definitely has
um the body modification
going on in
it
clubs
has to do with uh
uh [ __ ] what do you call them um
like not
environmentalism they're so
environmentalist that they're evolving
to eat the garbage of society in order
to kind of like pay for the sins of
mankind it's kind of what it's like
gotta clean this [ __ ] up cleaning this
[ __ ] up we're just gonna eat it
and it's just
and uh what else might not be a bad idea
it wouldn't be possible
but uh i'm just i'm making
so they become toxic themselves kind of
kind of deal and thrive in it
he's just turning the [ __ ] up to 11. you
know he's uh being
uh you know [ __ ] critical
i guess would be a good way to put it
which i like it yeah well and he's also
kind of i don't know
the thing about david cronenberg is that
i think a lot of his films like i said
are like satirical yeah but his sense of
humor is so dry yeah it comes off that i
think some people like maybe don't
because this movie for sure
there was like some funny [ __ ] in it
like not funny haha but
dryly funny i mean kristen stewart's
character how she was just constantly
like she seemed like she was just on the
verge of like orgasming all the time
like the way she was talking and stuff
that was like i thought that was like
kind of hilarious yeah the thing with
that is you know the vigo uh his
character what was his name saul yeah
salt tenser yeah i liked i like how they
had him dressed up okay uh
i have some some of those types of
outfits that he had with the [ __ ]
hoods and the [ __ ] you know like we
got from what you call it yeah he looked
kind of like i got a couple of those
what is that assassin's creed like
ninja or something yeah so he's dressed
like that and he's like a uh
he's basically kind of like a [ __ ]
club superstar almost like a rock star
to to these people who are into this
weird fetish yeah everybody knows they
just know this guy
so
at the registry board you know they just
see him as a [ __ ] superstar
and it's an old guy and this young chick
and they both want to [ __ ] screw him
basically
both trying to secretly put moves on him
that's how much they love him
and the girl is [ __ ] constantly just
creaming in her pants talking to him
yeah basically yeah
[Laughter]
and he's trying to figure out he's
trying to be cool with it but and and
what's funny is that you know he's got
to be in his 60s
vigo i'd say he's in his 60s
he's in real good shape though i mean
if you're gonna be 60 that's what you
want to look like
you probably really like you'd probably
really like eastern promises actually
he's in that too that's also david
karner so i guess he's he's the mick
jagger he's the mick jagger of surgery
yeah essentially i mean
well the thing about it is i think they
kind of get into because he's i don't
know if he's necessarily making fun of
performance art but he is kind of like
doing a little bit of a satire on it
yeah i think he was like body mod and
stuff because the thing about it is that
you know in this day and age like
whenever this is supposed to be because
nobody feels any pain anymore usually
well most people don't like some people
still do
but because nobody does and nobody gets
infected
so basically um you know
all of these people like everybody's
trying to be it's it's almost kind of
like everyone's trying to be like the
new the latest tick-tock sensation yeah
but the thing about it is that i mean
even though tick-tock the internet and
anything like that in the movies the
universe does not exist no they just
have cameras yeah old-fashioned cameras
and some of them are old-fashioned and
some of them are new like a ring that
just have like a camera on it like that
yeah that's right but then some of them
are like look like for they're from the
90s like little digital cameras from the
90s like little sony's or whatever so i
thought that was kind of funny but
so so the thing about it is that
saul and caprice i guess they've been
doing it longer and he's the one that
um that is like super good at it because
all of them they're just kind of like
well they're cutting themselves up um
you know because they don't feel any
pain and blah blah blah but since he's
amazing at growing all of these organs
um which actually that one other
character that told me he's like oh you
got anything new cooking in there you
know what i mean yeah and he's like well
i don't really have any control over it
but he keeps growing them and it seems
to be like speeding up so obviously he's
kind of like top of the heat because he
keeps growing all of these new organs
that they can subsequently remove which
other performance artists they don't
have that angle
so they're like way good at it and they
seem to have been doing it for a longer
time but now you get like all these
other and you do get to see like i think
they showed in the trailer like that guy
that had like his eyes and lips like
sewn shut and had like ears all over
them and stuff so they show like a
little bit of that and they show like a
little bit of like other kind of more
standard bless you sweetie yeah he's
over there sneezing they show other kind
of like more standard like body mod type
stuff like a woman that has like her
face all cut up and everything like that
like she gets that done but he's the
only one that actually they have this
autopsy machine and they go in there
like a remote control and they take all
the organs out and she actually like
tattoos them while they're still in
there right yeah i think they said that
too yeah adriana if that's your favorite
ones you'd probably like this one
yeah um grampner said uh which one is
more whack like weird um dead ringers or
crimes of the future um
this one's weirder this one is more
grotesque i mean dead ringers is
probably i don't know i was going to say
it's probably my favorite um david
cronenberg but all of them are
i mean video drone and the fly and
everything like that
the fly is not like a cronenberg movie
and though in the way that it's pretty
coherent it's like a big it's like a big
budget hollywood movie yeah that's his
most accessible yeah
spielberg could have made that movie
this is this is definitely a cronenberg
movie i mean adriana if you haven't seen
um
brood you need to see the brood that's
my i think the the brood might be my
favorite kronenberg movie i mean yeah
the people you might like it better than
video drone even though i do like video
grooming yeah the combination is really
good it's weird yeah
i guess well dead ringers for me i think
it was because maybe
i don't know i just have like a really
soft smart soft spot for that one and
it's just kind of like and that one is
even i mean it's weird but it's not like
one of his weirder ones this one's way
weirder and like way more grotesque then
as far as like the imagery goes yeah um
you know dead ringers was more
psychological like it had some kind of
disturbing images and stuff in it as far
as body horror but it was more
psychological he did scanners too didn't
he he did yeah i like scanners also i
don't have scanners see they're all good
i need to get scatters they're all good
yeah and you know even even as earlier
ones like shivers and yeah and all that
kind of stuff but
yeah i mean this one if you like
cronenberg i don't see why you wouldn't
like this one it is
very
it's very slow it's very expository like
i said um so there's a lot of
dialogue heavy scenes and a lot of the
dialogue is kind of like very
elevated and like pretentious but it's
like that on purpose i guess you're not
sure you know exactly what they're
talking about right and they're using
double meanings and stuff yeah but it
does have like a really lot of
[ __ ] up
imagery in it yeah so if that's what
you're
if that's what you're looking for it
definitely is like a return to form i
can't believe like david cronenberg is
almost 80. yeah he's on zack says does
anybody else find it kind of weird that
brandon basically cribbed his dad's
style for his own movies
uh
i don't think that's very unusual though
because it wouldn't surprise me if if uh
if his dad might have had something to
do with with with him making those moves
they might have been he might have
helped him want it
but i think i think his movies were good
yeah and you you would go see a
cronenberg movie to see that kind of
movie so i think that's probably the
right
angle to take you know like if there was
a spielberg jr making movies he would be
doing it like in his dad's style
i mean the thing about it is that how
much of it is just like oh cribbing his
dad's style or you know that's
genetically that's your dad and he was
around all the time so you were
influenced by him as well so it's like i
so i don't know if it's necessarily
maybe they're just like interested in
the same [ __ ]
yeah and that's why i mean you know yeah
it could just be that the movie i saw
that he did i liked it
yeah possessor was really good you'd
probably like antiviral too and that i
saw that one actually it might be free i
saw that one like a few months back
because i did it for my uh i reviewed it
for my other series
but i think it was on
it might have been on 2b because i don't
think i paid to watch it
but yeah that was his first one
but
yeah this is um it's definitely like a
return to form it reminded me very much
of existence but the thing about it is
that last time i watched existence i
used to really like that movie when it
first i saw in the theater when it came
out in 1999 and then i saw it a couple
times subsequently i think i watched it
again like a year or two ago and it
seemed weirdly it seemed like futuristic
but also seemed like really dated it
seemed like very very late 90s computer
hacker type uh stuff
um
but
so but this is along the same lines
but it's not about a virtual reality
game it's essentially just like
and it's not supposed to be you know
what the weird thing i'd and i had
forgotten i had forgotten completely
about this and that's why like the title
crimes of the future like sounded so
familiar to me was because david
cronenberg made a movie called crimes of
the future back in 1970
it was like an hour long movie but it
doesn't really have anything to do with
this one i think in that one
some character like mentioned something
like about sex and surgery or something
like that but it wasn't the movie wasn't
really about that so i don't really know
why he titled it the same thing other
than just being like cheeky that's what
he is
maybe
but yeah i mean if you like cronenberg
it's definitely worth seeing like i said
it is
it's kind of slow and it's kind of
but i mean i really dug it and i kind of
want to watch it again because like i
said i think i missed like a lot of
uh i didn't know honestly it was slow
yeah i had i didn't really see it as
being slow
no
it seemed to seem normal to me i mean i
was entertained through the whole thing
yeah i mean i was too i was too right i
just thought it was funny like a few
times it's funny because like i said we
were in the theater at night and there
was only one other guy in there and so
like a couple times when some real
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like happened in the
movie tom just like just like laughed
out loud and she's like man cronenberg
yeah
it's not uh super disturbing though in
the way you know i've seen much worse
it's just chronic does weird [ __ ] i mean
yeah i mean if you've seen any of his
other movies i don't think it's gonna
like alarm you or anything um you know
because he always does [ __ ] like that
now if you're just like somebody that
doesn't watch horror movies or he hasn't
seen any of his other movies yeah you
might think it's like kind of [ __ ] up
but
i the only thing that i thought i don't
want to like spoil it because i think
mango just came in and said he's trying
to avoid spoilers um there was one thing
it didn't shock me but i was surprised
that he went as far as he went with it
if you've seen it you probably know what
i'm talking about
but
um yeah so i was surprised like oh well
okay he went there but you know that's
that was the only thing that i was just
kind of like surprised by
but yeah there's a lot of you go see it
it's good yeah it's yeah it's good
definitely i mean it's definitely worth
watching definitely worth watching
uh yeah mango said cronenberg is up
there with kubrick for me yeah
definitely yeah that's good yeah it's
like a video drum and brood you know
it's kind of a return to what he
normally does it's got a little bit of
everything
it's even got like [ __ ] from dead
ringers is kind of in it it's it's good
yeah good it's like what he normally
does yeah
so yeah everybody go see it and then
tell us what you think about it
all right so are we done yep okay yeah
like i said we don't want to spoil too
much yeah because can't talk anymore
about it because uh yeah it's super new
but yeah so
i guess that'll do it for this review
now tomorrow's wednesday so tomorrow is
the main show
and we're talking about the navajo code
talkers or the native american code
talkers they weren't all navajo i think
like the navajo the best known ones but
so we're going to talk about that so
that should be an entertaining show that
one in the poll so we'll see everybody
tomorrow evening and have a good rest of
your day bye